bonsoir la crise du coc vide n'est pas
terminée mais la politique elle est
sortie de son confinement depuis déjà
quelques temps les différentes affaires
de violences d' attaques de forces de
l'ordre sont revenus immédiatement sur
le devant de la scène
autant dire que ça va faire débat
jusqu'à la présidentielle au risque
d'être parfois dans une surenchère sur
les mesures sécuritaires
tous les gouvernements depuis des
décennies se sont heurtés aux réalités
qui vont plus vite que la législation
avec par ailleurs la concurrence du
rassemblement national dans ce rôle de
pousse au crime politique
ce soir dans l'émission publique le
rendez vous politique lcp public sénat
avec le figaro nous recevons annie
genevard bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes vice
présidente de l'assemblée nationale vous
êtes aussi présents du conseil national
des républicains et député du tout
on va parler d'un de vos collègues
guillaume pelletier à la fois collègues
députés mais aussi à la direction dlr et
les numéros de votre parti il a fait
fort hier il a proposé sur rtl une
justice d'exception contre les
terroristes et dit même s'il faut
changer la constitution pour en allait
aller jusque-là ballon si à un mois des
régionales où le rn je disais joue sur
les questions de sécurité est ce qu'il
n'a pas fait une erreur stratégique
bah écoutez il a fait cavalier seul ce
qui est un politique n'est jamais bon
quand ça quand ça pour conséquence de
fragiliser la formation politique à
laquelle on appartient et dont on est
l'un des dirigeants
donc je regrette cette prise de position
qui n'avait été validé par par personne
discuté par ocam des membres de la
direction du parti
voilà donc c'est une prise de position
qui n'engage que lui et en aucune façon
la direction des républicains parce que
des jacobins raison de rappeler qu'en
politique il faut jouer collectif
surtout en période électorale
ça vous a surpris on reconnaît guillaume
pelletier c'est un homme de talent de
grand talent mais qui a le goût de la
provocation et de l'idée qui dérange
donc il est je dirais dans conforme à sa
nature mais dans des périodes aussi
sensible que celle que nous connaissons
à la fois sur les questions de sécurité
et en même temps en période électorale
je crois que il est impératif que de
toujours se rappeler qu'on a le devoir
de jouer collectif comme le dit neutre
notre patron christian jacob
alors on va revenir sur le fond de ces
propositions tout à l'heure sur les
conséquences politiques éventuellement
mais en tant que dirigeante de l air
qu'est ce que vous attendez de vos
collègues qui sont dans la direction des
républicains
quels qu'ils soient pas rappelé que oui
est ce que vous demandez plus de
collectif plus de discrétion à tout le
monde
est ce que c'est un message pour
guillaume petty ou est ce que il faut
l'élargir à tous les dirigeants dlr août
et moi je suis membre de la direction de
de mon parti je travaille étroitement
avec les membres de l'équipe dirigeante
et avec christian jacob ce que je vois
c'est que nous savons jouer collectif
nous travaillons le fond les conventions
se multiplient les adhérents reviennent
christian jacob a remis autour de la
table les principales figures de notre
formation politique il discute avec ceux
qui sont partis je pense aux
particuliers valérie pécresse et xavier
bertrand donc nous savons jouer
collectif et il faut pas que la la la
sortie de piste de l'un d'entre nous ne
laisse à penser que c'est un phénomène
généralisé et que chacun dit la sienne
non nous avons à plusieurs reprises
montré que nous savions parler d'une
même voix et c'est ça que je veux
retenir
d'autant qu'en matière de sécurité nous
avons fait des propositions extrêmement
précises porter les budgets de la
justice et de la police
1 % du pipe pendant 5 ou sur cinq ans
déconstruire 20000 places de prison les
peines planchers la justice des mineurs
et cetera terrain on a des positions
crédit précise et c'est celle là que je
veux retenir c'est forcément guillaume
petit mais on va revenir j'ai
surveillons pettis son rôle le rôle qui
pourra jouer ou pas à l'avenir à la tête
de l air mais on accueille ce soir comme
tous les lundis soir brigitte boucher de
lcp bonsoir 20,6 et bonsoir six jours
d'un bon jeu physique sénat qui ont vous
interrogez d'abord sur le co vide parce
que oui les la crise sanitaire et n'est
pas terminée brigitte oui pour soeur
annie genevard depuis aujourd'hui tous
les français de plus de 18 ans peuvent
se faire vacciner ce que d'après vous ça
y est on est en train de sortir de la
crise je l'espère il faut le souhaiter
pour notre pays pour les français pour
ceux qui veulent venir visiter notre
pays le tourisme est complètement à
l'arrêt depuis
de nombreux mois pour pour la vie
quotidienne évidemment on ne peut que
souhaiter en sortir on l'attend espérer
et à de très nombreuses reprises
espérant que celle-ci soit soit la bonne
je rappelle que cette crise elle a été
marquée par des espoirs déçus par des
erreurs stratégiques par des défauts de
logistique par tout un tas de désordre
dont il faudra absolument tirer les
enseignements il ya une commission
denquête mais aujourd'hui il ya une
sorte de plafond de verre sur la
vaccination pour atteindre l'immunité
collective emmanuel macron n'exclut plus
aujourd'hui de vacciner de façon
obligatoire
est ce que vous vous y être favorables
moi je pense que ce serait en l'état une
assez mauvaise idée et qu'il faut tout
faire pour pour l'éviter pourquoi parce
que rendre la vaccination obligatoire
c'est courir le risque de voir des
oppositions fortes se manifester vous
savez qu'il ya il ya des gens qui sont
radicalement hostile à la vaccination
pour eux mêmes pour leurs familles c'est
d'ailleurs un vrai sujet de santé
publique
mais il faut laisser à chacun la liberté
de ceux de se vacciner ou de ne pas se
vacciner maintenant si ça compromet les
musiques et collective de tout le pays
il faudra peut-être engager d'autres
actions faudra-t-il subordonnés
certaines activités à la vaccination
voilà mais de là à la rendre obligatoire
je pense que c'est un pas à franchir qui
serait périlleux pour la cohésion
nationale
alors il ya plusieurs fabricants de
vaccins qui se voudrait élargir la
vaccination aux 12 17 ans est-ce que ça
ça vous paraît nécessaire justement pour
tenter d'atteindre cette immunité
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas on sait que
les ados ont été des vecteurs de
contamination parce que là ils ont moins
le sens des distances que les avec le
visuel de questions et de faire des
contraires ah oui il m'a dit c'est pour
ça qu'on ne ferme pas les écoles et les
collèges
non mais moi j'ai pensé oui enfin
quiconque a dans sa famille des
adolescents c'est qu'il ya eu des
contaminés solide à côté de la plaque
jean michel blanc la contamination ne se
fait pas nécessairement à l'école
c'était ça doit être là la subtilité ce
qui est sûr et là où je rejoins le
ministre l'éducation nationale c'est qu'
il fallait tout faire pour laisser les
établissements scolaires ouverts ces
thèmes majeurs viennent voir le pass
sanitaire a été adopté la semaine
dernière par le parlement le conseil
constitutionnel vient tout juste de
valider ce pass sanitaire vous vous en
féliciter nous nous avons voté le pass
annie terre en le faisant évoluer tout
de même 1 il ne vous a pas échappé
qu'entre le moment où le texte est
arrivé notamment ses parlement et le
moment où nous l'avons voté il ya quand
même eu des évolutions significatives
pour ce que vous aviez voté contre
derrière ne serait ce que parce que nous
voulions que le passé ni terre ne soit
réservée qu'à certaines activités qui
mettait en présence de très un très
grand nombre de personnes 2000 perf en
voulait que soient prises en compte la
densité pas seulement le chiffre de 1000
personnes dans l'absolu tout dépend
aussi de la densité dans laquelle se
déploie ses mille personnes le regret
c'est que le couvre-feu continue le
cozic et plus façon de se ranger mais ce
qui est une façon de conserver un état
d'urgence sanitaire malgré le vide c'est
aussi l'aspect économique bruno le maire
parle aujourd'hui d'un déficit plus
important que prévu est ce que le quoi
qu'il en coûte doit prendre fin tout de
suite sur vous vous savez quoi qu'il en
coûte 7 à slogan ça n'est pas une
politique économique y est un beau coup
dead qui ont été donc
rare rarement les ministres ont eu de
telles marges de manoeuvre financières
et donc elles ont été distribuées très
largement il fallait aider évidemment le
tissu économique
faute de quoi il se serait effondrée
elle a aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il faut
arrêter ce alors il faut aller de façon
dégressive on ne peut pas rester dans
une situation qui menace la souveraineté
économique de nouvelles d'accord avec le
gouvernement il va proposer le
gouvernement 15 milliards d'aidé
d'urgence supplémentaires à partir de
mercredi un nouveau projet de loi sera
présenté en conseil des ministres ça
vous va 15 milliards d'êtres d'urgence
et poussant les secteurs les plus
touchés
à écouter les chiffres dans l'absolu ne
veulent rien dire il faut voir à quoi
ils seront utilisés
ce qui est certain c'est que la dette
s'envole le déficit se creuse le déficit
de la balance extérieure était dans une
situation absolument catastrophique
donc on a énormément de demandeurs
d'emploi entre 6 et 7 millions et et
paradoxalement beaucoup de difficultés à
trouver de la main d'oeuvre les
entreprises vous le dise donc on voit
bien que la machine économique est
complètement grippé et ben il ya une
incertitude sur l'avenir est ce que la
relance se fera mais vous ne voterez pas
ce projet de loi ben j'ai écouté on a
voté tous les collectifs budgétaires qui
concernait les aides aux entreprises
bien conjonction on peut pas être dans
la coup de financement sans avoir une
stratégie claire précise et qui donne
des perspectives aux entreprises
oui pour favoriser la relance vous vous
préconisez à droite une baisse de la tva
vous allez d'ailleurs déposé un
amendement à ce projet de loi de
finances rectificative pour quel secteur
vous le préconisez et est ce que pour
vous ce serait une baisse qui serait
temporaire ou même permanente
ce serait forcément une baisse ciblée on
ne peut pas avoir une baisse généralisée
tous les produits ne se valent pas par
exemple sur une enquête étendue de
première nécessité et des produits qui
sont moins de six mois
immédiatement nécessaires à la vie il ya
des produits dont on souhaite voir
augmenter la consommation parce que
c'est bon pour le pays c'est par exemple
la france
voilà donc bon tout ça va se discuter
entre nous donc je réserve nos annonces
entre vous à dire écoute on chez les
républicains
cette caisse qui entre parlementaires
non non mais entre parlementaires de ma
nous avons notre réunion de groupe cette
question sera débattue donc les choses
vont être examinés à ce moment là mais
l'aïe pas encore tranchée de la tva la
tvh c'est un impôt qui a une base très
très large
donc c'est un levier qui peut se révéler
extraordinairement utile salaires flou
quand même pas ce que vous dites ce sera
tranché demain enfin iranien a l'air un
peu floue oui oui mais écoutez cette
question elle est pour moi en suspens je
ne lis pas particulièrement travaillé
avec les intéressés et les membres de la
commission des finances encore là
pourquoi je reste est encore imprécise
dans ma réponse j'étais comme vous ne
l'avez dit c'est beaucoup de rentrées
fiscales la tva 45 milliards au total
comment on compense ce manque à gagner
pour l'état si on baisse la tva même
dans certains secteurs seulement
vous savez un budget se construit avec
des dépenses des recettes nous qui
sommes des qui avant étaient des élus
locaux nous savons bien comment se
construit l'équilibré d'un budget sous
ce quinquennat les choses ont été
souvent mal maîtrisé je rappelle que
avant la crise qu'ovide plus de dépenses
plus de déficit plus d'impôts est
l'exemple emblématique c'est la crise
des gilet jaune doubs est elle née c'est
l'augmentation de la fiscalité sur les
carburants qui n'avait pas d'autres
compensations que l'augmentation vous
vous commencez vous compenser par quoi
cette baisse de la tva mais écoutez
j'imagine comme je voulais dit je ne
suis pas oui c'est pas votre spécialité
non d'accord c'est pas trop ça n'est pas
ma spécialité c'est que je n'ai pas
travaillé avec l'accord des membres de
la commission des finances sur vous
voulez pas les ouvriers
je ne sais pas que je ne veux pas les
spoilers je ne veux pas faire de réponse
qui trahissent leur projet de gîte est
ce que pour réduire les déficits
à droite vous seriez prêt à relancer la
réforme des retraites celle de françois
fillon
la retraite à 65 ans la réforme des
retraites et une réforme majeure parce
que est d'ailleurs le corps qui est qui
et qui est l'instance qui le conseil
d'orientation des retraites conseil
d'orientation des retraites qui est
chargé d'examiner toutes les questions
relatives à la pérennité du système de
retraites
alerte sur le fait que si aucune mesure
n'est prise dans un avenir proche
le système ne s'équilibre plus donc j'ai
hâte et justement si le gouvernement ne
fait pas la réforme des retraites avant
la fin du quinquennat ce serait une
erreur pour vous à ce serait une erreur
profonde mais pas n'importe quel fan à
même les fins que celles de france à
seillans question forcer sur ses leçons
françois fillon pas la même réforme le
président de la république a voulu faire
je dirais dans une attitude un peu
bravache faire ce qu avant lui personne
n'avait jamais fait c'est à dire une
réforme systémique qu'on bouge pour mais
tout le système bon suscitant les
désordres que nous avons vu parce que
bien souvent emmanuel macron a été un
président du désordre et les
manifestations avec les débordements que
nous avons vu les attaques de policiers
de forces de l'ordre tout ça tout ça est
née d'une réforme qui n'a pas été
suffisamment pensés et du reste le
premier ministre de l'époque edouard
philippe voulait introduire une mesure
d'âge ce que ne voulait pas faire
emmanuel max que vous voulez faire ce
que nous ne voulons fermer donc la
lourde réforme des retraites tradition
françois fillon elle est toujours dans
le programme de la droite là si on ne
prend pas une mesure d'âge si on ne
prend pas une mesure d'âge pour allonger
le temps la durée du travail
de toute façon il n'ya pas trente-six
paramètres soient vous augmenter les
cotisations sont faveur de questions
hors de question soit vous diminuer les
pensions hors de question soit vous
bouger l'âge de départ l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite fait là pour cet
essai sur ce levier là plutôt que sur
celui des cotisations ou du montant des
pensions que nous voulons jouer les
russes avant de passer la parole à 65
ans pardon vous êtes toujours sur 65 ans
alors on veut non c'est quelque chose
qui doit être tout à fait progressif il
faut appeler les annuités de travail la
durée il faut prendre en compte les
carrières longues enfin voilà alors
avant de parler d'antiterrorisme avec
steve juste pour bien me comprendre vous
dites si emmanuel macron ne fait pas la
réforme maintenant c'est une erreur dont
vous dites à emmanuel macron fait la
réforme avant la fin du quinquennat
alors moi je dis que qui emmanuel macron
qui se veut le président de la réforme
aura fort peut réformer en réel oui mais
est-ce que vous lui dites vous lui avez
bien sûr qu'il faut réformer avant la
fin de son quinquennat il doit ici doit
s'y est engagé à écouter
c'est une réforme qui ne supportera pas
qu'on attendait définivement parce que
le déficit va se creuser s'est installé
il ya eu je le mettais au défi de le
faire quoi en fait
écoutez je ne mets pas je ne sais pas si
on peut formuler les choses comme ça ce
que je sais c'est que c'est un président
qui prétend vouloir réformer jusqu'au
bout donc il le prouve pas qu'il le
prouve qu'il le prouve mais jusqu'à ce
qu'ils s'y prennent autrement parce que
jusqu'à quand j'entends si les thèmes
très mal pris on va parler de delà du
projet de loi anti-terrorisme projet
doit effectivement antiterroriste sera
examiné demain à l'assemblée c'est le
20ème texte anti terroriste en 35 ans
droite gauche sentent même combat
qu'est-ce qu'on n'arrive pas à faire
contre le terrorisme en france
déjà la situation est allé s'aggravant
c'est un phénomène qui monte en
puissance et qui menacent nos
démocraties alors il ya plusieurs façons
d'aborder le sujet il y a la réponse
immédiate ce que ces lois d'urgence
prétend de faire des lois répétition
d'ailleurs les français s'ils perdent un
peu
on voit bien que la loi citée puis
maintenant la loi antiterroriste qui est
la loi séparatisme certains il est
choisi à la loi visant à restaurer la
confiance avec la justice il n'y a pas
de lisibilité à cette succession
effrénée de réformes et que par ailleurs
qu'ils ne parviennent pas à juguler le
phénomène de la radicalisation qui est
le vrai terreau du terrorisme alors la
question c'est est-ce que vous la droite
vous feriez mieux que le rayonnement
actuel - me donner un exemple du home
petit numéro 2 de votre parti guy
teissier encore lui propose le retour
d'une justice d'exception en matière de
terrorisme justice d'exception sur la
base de soupçons avérés sans possibilité
d'appel est ce que vous y êtes favorable
non je crois que nous avons été très
clairs à ce sujet nous avons dit que la
proposition guillaume pelletier n'était
pas à la proposition des républicains
s'agit pas de faire de mettre en place
une justice d'exception qui a je crois a
été abandonné avec françois mitterrand
donc elle a existé dans le passé on
était pas pour autant en dictature donc
il faut aussi relativiser les choses
mais des états unis on met cette anaky
et je crois que c'est ça n'est pas à un
moment où la france est très fracturé
sur ces questions de régaliennes je n'ai
pas le moment d'introduire un élément
qui pourrait être perçu comme une
fragilisation d'un des totems d'un état
de droit et la lutte contre le
terrorisme et est adroit il faut choisir
selon non bien sûr que non bien sûr que
non dans la mesure où le terrorisme
menace l'état de droit donc il est clair
que là il faut prendre toute la mesure
de la gravité du phénomène et y ait dans
la loi séparatisme qu'on va bientôt
examiné en commission le ministre de
l'intérieur n'a pas voulu qu'on parle de
radicalisation a voulu qu'on parle de
radicalisation c'était pas le sujet or
c'est précisément le sujet parce que le
le radicalisme qui est le terreau du
terrorisme se nourrit de ce séparatisme
culturelles identitaires politique que
représente l'islam politique
donc il y a tout à reprendre de la base
mais ça c'est une entreprise de très
longue haleine de très longue haleine
et puis il faut arrêter aussi de
fragiliser nos préfets nos ambassadeurs
nos policiers et nos gendarmes enfin
tout aujourd'hui tous les piliers de
l'état
de droit sont aujourd'hui dans un état
de protestations
vous avez des tribunes dans tous les
sens l'armée fait des tribunes la police
fait des tribus les préfets fond des
tripes sur le régalien aux ambassadeurs
donc il faut il faut pas fragiliser nos
institutions au moment où on doit livrer
bataille contre le terrorisme
oui dans ce projet de loi antiterroriste
il ya aussi le renforcement du suivi des
personnes qui sont condamnées pour
terrorisme et qui sortent de prison
le gouvernement propose deux ans de
suivi vous demander plus et si oui
combien de temps parce qu on a
effectivement l'impression que les
personnes peuvent passer à l'acte à
n'importe quel moment
alors ça c'est un énorme problème je
crois qu'entre 2020 et 2021 c'est près
d'une centaine de personnes qui seront
libérés et si on ne fait rien qu'ils
peuvent à nouveau comme être alors je
les spécialistes s'affrontent sur le
sujet comment comment traitez vous voyez
à certains sont sous bracelet
électronique et ont commis des actes
abominables donc il y a là un défi
majeur pour nos démocraties
une surveillance de deux ans ne
l'empêchera pas la troisième année il
faut donc mettre en place des outils
extrêmement serré et puis des instances
qui puisse pouvoir empêcher la
commission de nouveaux faits mais ça ça
peut pas d'un suivi permanent jusqu'à la
fin ça veut pas être un suivi permanent
c'est bien la raison pour laquelle je
vous disais que tout est à reprendre à
la base et que je pars dans la
constitution aussi faut la revoir
moi j'étais favorable à ce qu'on touche
à la constitution sur ces questions
alors pas forcément pour le projet de
cour de sûreté mais par exemple pour
lutter efficacement contre le
séparatisme
nous avions dans le droit fil de ce que
proposait le sénat voulu modifier la
constate la constitution pour empêcher
les listes communautaires aux élections
et pour dire que personne ne pouvait se
dérober à la règle commune
parce qu'aujourd'hui les messages sont
affreux emmanuel macron nous dit non
mais vous étiez pour le changement la
concession est plus maintenant mais on
peut pas changer la constitution
changement de la constitution n'est pas
fait pour vous josé pied pour donc
j'entends que maintenant vous n'êtes
plus on vous y attend peut être
favorable pour changer la constitution
sur certains points mais pas sur
d'autres accords originels évoqué
effectivement le cas de cet ancien
militaire qui a été neutralisée en
dordogne qui avait été condamné quatre
fois pour violences conjugales qui
portait un bracelet électronique
or on sait très bien que c'est aurélien
pradié qui a fait voter à l'unanimité ce
port du bracelet électronique
visiblement c'est pas suffisant qu'est
ce qu'est ce qu'on peut faire de plus
alors faut une politique résolue il ya
des pays qui ont réussi
la violence intrafamiliale je pense à
l'espagne en particulier en mettant
beaucoup plus de moyens en mettant
certainement beaucoup plus de moyens
staff les eaux
quand je pense qu autrefois le crime
passionnel était comment dirais-je était
une circonstance atténuante quand on
voit aujourd'hui le nombre de femmes qui
se font massacrer dans des conditions
absolument épouvantable là il ya une
prise de conscience a cédé mais il
faudra des moyens supplémentaires faudra
les moyens enfin le bracelet
électronique que non que n'at-il été
fait avant il a fallu que ce soit ait
l'air comme souvent d'ailleurs nous
propose est le sien dans les actions ça
ne suffit pas mais c'est quand même un
élément il est dommage d'ailleurs que le
conseil constitutionnel ait retoqué les
drones
parce que quelqu'un qui enlève son
bracelet électronique ou qu'ils
s'écartent de la zone dans laquelle il
est confiné peut immédiatement être
repéré par un drone moi je regrette
beaucoup que cette disposition était
censurée par le conseil constitutionnel
merci brigitte merci steve vous parliez
des prêts faits tout à l'heure justement
mercredi le texte supprimant le corps
des préfets venu présenter en conseil
des ministres ce sera une ordonnance et
la fonction reste mais sera créé un
futur cordes administrateurs de l'état
pour diversifier les profils ouvrir la
fonction à d'autres profils c'est ce que
veut faire le gouvernement
est-ce que vous la fin du corps
préfectoral c'est à dire cette espèce de
deux lignes de voilà ce corps
préfectoral cette profession en tant que
tel le stade le statut reste en revanche
est ce que ça vous gêne à moussa me gêne
beaucoup
ça me gêne beaucoup parce que je ne
comprends pas le sens de cette réforme
si les préfets avaient démérité oui mais
les préfets et les maires ont été
absolument exemplaire pendant la crise
sanitaire ils ont démontré d'abord qu'il
faisait face avec beaucoup de sang froid
et deuxièmement que il était en capacité
de compenser
il manque les manquements des agences
régionales de santé ou de la mise en
oeuvre des préconisations du
gouvernement ils ont été très utiles et
nous qui travaillons très souvent avec
eux nous savons que ce sont des idées
des gens de très grande valeur dont il
faut regarder la réalité à l'état qui
sont conscients de leur mission qui sont
pas mais moi je soupçonne emmanuel
macron de vouloir réduire à ce de
vouloir mettra sa main ce corps
préfectoral et je pense que ce n'est pas
le sens de nos institutions ni d'un
fonctionnement respectueux qu'il faut
garder le corps préfectoral jubilé je
pense qu'il faut enfin je suis d'avis
qu'il faut garder le corps préfectoral
qui n'a pas démérité
pourquoi vouloir tout casser il très
rare il tient ici directeur adjoint du
figaro nous a rejoint comme tous les
lundis soir bonsoir yves bonsoir francis
bonsoir indigènes l'art bonsoir revient
à guillaume pelletier parce que
guillaume pelletier a exprimé aussi sa
proximité avec robert bédard le maire de
béziers est bon ça n'a pas l'air de
salah pas l'heur de plaire à tout le
monde chez vous est-ce qu'il faut après
tout pas lui demander de partir de
quitter sa vice-présidence et
éventuellement de partie comme vous y
allez très rare je vous inquiète
toujours
non elle la mollesse que vous pouvez
parfois reproché à emmanuel macron
finalement on la retrouve chez goût là
non rassurez vous il ya des explications
de textes qui vont être faites de
gravure des gravures pu rester à son
poste
alors vous savez je crois qu au moment
où on est engagé dans un combat
électoral c'est pas le moment de couper
des têtes ni de se faire
du mal à soi même explication interne y
en aura mais après il peut y avoir du
soui mais guillaume pelletier n'a pas
été suivi tout le monde a réprouvé cette
prise de position solitaire isolé c'est
regrettable parce qu'elle fragilise le
collectif et donc qu'ils en tirent les
enseignements
sauf sauf quelques-uns quand même nadine
morano députée européenne dit bah moi
dans l'intérêt général
je suis prêt à travailler à voter pour
mal avec leurs aînés avec le rêve alors
ça fait du monde tout ça comme non non
enfin je propose qu il y a chez il ya
différents cas de figure nadine morano
vous le savez a eu un coup de colère
liée à la configuration de la liste dans
sa région
moi les déclarations que j'ai entendu
d'elle n'était pas un ralliement ou
rassemblement national simplement elle
traduit ce que nous sentons sur le
terrain qui échappent peut-être aux
éditorialistes et une partie de la
classe politique qui est complètement
obsédé par cette question du front du
front républicain et qui ne voient pas
que les français sont passés à autre
chose vous vous êtes contre le front
républicain non je ne suis pas contre le
front publica je dis simplement monsieur
finale en même temps alors non non non
je fais pas duré le temps je dis
simplement attention nous nous avons un
prisme de spécialistes tout
professionnel de la politique et que
l'opinion publique nous dit
régulièrement arrêter de vous perdre
dans ces querelles sémantiques et ses
querelles de valeur occupez vous des
français et des problèmes que que la
france traverse et qui serait grave
néanmoins ni j'adore pour faire bas
à un candidat rassemblement national ou
à marine le pen dans le cadre d'une
présidentielle
ça voudrait dire que vous vous mettez un
petit peu en rupture avec les gens dont
vous parlez et vous vous adoptez le
front républicain
je dis simplement que dans une élection
il ya deux tours au premier tour on
choisit au deuxième tour on élimine donc
il faut déjà s'occuper du premier tour
si vous m'interrogez sur le deuxième
tour de la présidentielle alors que nous
ne sommes même pas au premier tour des
régionales et d'aidés départementales
jeudi n'allons pas si vite en besogne
cette élection qui va clore tout le
cycle électoral va nous donner une
photographie politique de la france nous
verrons bien où sont les forces en
présence il est clair que aujourd'hui le
rassemblement national à une dynamique
pourquoi tout simplement parce que les
problèmes ne sont pas ne sont pas réglés
et que ils ont le sentiment que
peut-être avec le rassemblement national
ils le seront mieux ce qui est à leur
est une illusion et c'est la raison pour
laquelle aux républicains avec christian
jacob
nous sommes sur le travail de fond et
sur les propositions
il faut être dedans nous avons réussi
c'est pas les sénatoriales
nous sommes en passe de gagner les deux
législatives partielles cher cap fait
donc on verra bien moi j'ai donné on a
sélectionné même l'impression d'une
légère et qui n'est pas que légères
cacophonie après à l'intérieur de votre
parti politique on écoute eric woerth
par exemple et river te dis moi j'ai pas
les mêmes idées que guillaume pelletier
moi je refuse que en bourgogne
france-comté monsieur platret ça ceci
avec debout la france le candidat de
debout la france dont le président
aurait pu être le premier ministre de
mari de la peine et puis on a de l'autre
côté
monsieur eric ciotti qu'un discours
sécuritaire très affirmée et monsieur
guillaume pelletier qui propose une
augmentation de 20 % du smic qui est
très très loin de ce que dit eric faut
aérer eric darques justement alors où
êtes vous mais enfin vous connaissez la
politique comme moi elle est faite
d'individualités puissant qui existe
mais c'est le collectif qui compte
mais mais mais
ce qui importe c'est de voir qu'elle est
quelles sont les positions que nous
portons collectivement et qui évite ces
écarts spectaculaires ya une ligne sur
le plan économique sur le plan rien sur
le plan politique nous courrons sous nos
couleurs
et moi je vais vous dire j'en ai un peu
assez d'être toujours renvoyés à cette
sempiternelle question du rapport des
républicains avec le rassemblement
national
c'est un poison ce débat là à ceux qui
votent tel ou tel mais ce débat là que
françois mitterrand a instillé dans
l'opinion publique et dans la vie
politique française est fait pour
réduire les républicains marine le pen
et emmanuel macron ont un objectif
commun celui de nous réduire de nos
fracturé pour se partager nos dépouille
alors nous ne nous laissons pas faire
nous sommes la première force
d'opposition a aimé série ya eu
l'élection présidentielle qui se profile
dans quelques mois on sait qu'il ya
plusieurs prétendants à l'intérieur de
votre famille politique même s'ils sont
pas tous membres est encarté dans le
parti républicain est ce que c'est
d'allier bertrand qui semble se dégager
dans les codes en laisse aux études
d'opinion actuellement qui tient la
corde et qui a votre faveur
alors pour m'être engagé dans la
précédente élection présidentielle dans
une écurie
j'en ai vu toutes les limites et tous
les dangers les écuries ce sont des
machines à se faire mal à soi même
parler des primaires voilà je parle des
primaires et je parle aussi des écuries
c'est à dire de ces bataillons qui
s'engagent pour tel ou tel et qui
s'affrontent
ce n'est pas comme ça qu'on peut revenir
aux affaires clairement donc moi je me
rangerai résolument derrière celui ou
celle qui évidemment partagent nos idées
ça c'est la première la première
condition absolue et puis donc je pense
qu'elle est la mieux à même cette
personne de nous faire revenir aux
affaires parce que je crois que la
france a besoin
un d'un personnel politique nouveau avec
des jt claire un projet ferme et surtout
qui a l'expérience de la gestion des
affaires vous exercez deux personnes
deux personnes se dégagent du lot
aujourd'hui me semble-t-il c'est xavier
bertrand et c'est valérie pécresse les
sondages le montrent bon on le voit
parmi les prétendants des gens qui ne
sont plus aux élèves comme disait mais
comment vous avez partagé mais ils sont
plus haut et l'air mais mais mais tous
les deux appartiennent à notre famille
politique
comment vous allez les départager alors
ça c'est toute la question
donc ça doit être réglée quand tout ça
doit être réglée entre entre la fin du
mois de juin et le mois de septembre
octobre et l'automne vous savez quand on
regarde le timing des précédentes
élections présidentielles les choses les
déclarations de candidature ne se font
qu'à l'automne un courant l'automne donc
ne nous affolons pas mais cela dit je
pense que il faut assez rapidement qu'on
détermine notre candidat sans veiller à
vide dans une primaire la primaire telle
qu'on l'a connue non et d'ailleurs les
adhérents et une autre forme de
primaires alors une autre farnerud
primaire interne ça a ses limites aussi
il faut je pense une combinaison de
critères et vous pouvez compter sur
gérard larcher pour la trouver entre
autres mais je sais que gérard larcher
et christian jacob ils réfléchissent
nous n'avons pas voulu qu'il ya un
groupe de travail parce que
immédiatement ça aurait fuité dans tous
les sens et ça vous aurait occupé des
mois durant
ça nous aurait certainement fragilisé je
regrette pour vous mais il valait mieux
que ces choses-là soit faite dans dans
une relative discrétion dans un premier
temps bon alors on verra comment tout ça
sortira merci merci francis merci du
leader
et votre collègue député bénédicte
taurine la france a soumises de l'ariège
a été projetée à terre ouvre les images
lors d'une manifestation devant pôle
emploi à paris par un policier elle
avait son écharpe tricolore était
reconnaissable
est ce que ces images vous choque oui
c'est choquant bien sûr c'est choquant
de voir quelqu'un se faire molester un
jt c'est pas quelqu'un sait il est de
surcroît et j'allais dire et de surcroît
ça d'une écharpe tricolore représentant
la nation puisque c'est le rôle des
députés
c'est choquant et ça mérite
effectivement des explications
alors justement richarté en présent de
l'assemblée nationale demande des
explications mises l'intérieur gérald
darmanin qu'est ce que vous en attendez
que je pense qu'il y aura une enquête
interne de l'inspection générale de la
police où est-ce que ça suffit je ne
sais pas il faut voir ce qui s'est passé
quelles ont été les circonstances de de
tout cela mais les images tel qu'on nous
les voyons une députée une élue une
femme lestés ainsi c'est ce n'est pas
acceptable
andré chassaigne qui est présent du
groupe communiste à l'assemblée demande
que demain à l'occasion des questions au
gouvernement
richard ferrand exprime son soutien à la
députée vous soutenez cette idée écoutez
je ne sais pas si richard ferrand
souscrira en tout cas à mon avis richard
ferrand a déjà exprimé son soutien à
cette député parce qu'il doit le faire
pour enfants l'a fait publiquement
demandant des explications à gérald
darmanin doit-il aller au delà je ne
sais pas il me salue votre avis qui doit
présidente je pense qu'il ya une enquête
qui va être qui va être diligentée et ça
suffit et dès lors non ça ne suffit pas
mais ça y établira les circonstances
précises
de ceux de ces faits qui sont en soi
répréhensible et dont la captation des
images est évidemment choquant
on va maintenant accueillir les deux
parlementaires qui vont débattre avec
vous alors deux parlementaires à john
tbonds soir et bernard jomier bonsoir je
vous présente un par un agent et vous
êtes député des français de l'étranger
pour parole de la république en marche à
l'assemblée nationale bernard jomier
vous êtes sénateur ps de paris est vous
êtes à la tête de plusieurs commissions
notamment commission d' enquête sur le
co lead et sur les lois bioéthiques l on
va parler tout ça justement ce soir et
on va commencer avec vous à john t parce
que vous voulez parler justement du coc
vide je te fais parler du coe j
parce que dans le cas de la gestion de
la crise sanitaire j'ai noté que bien
souvent chez les républicains
les points de vue il suffisait de
regarder à l'opposé de ce que nous
proposions pour qu'il nous propose à peu
près le contraire et il nous proposait
dans la direction compte contraire donc
c'était quand on n'en fait pas assez on
fait pas assez vide on va trop lentement
c'était on en fait trop on n'en fait pas
assez c'était voilà toujours des leçons
parfois nous donne et qui était un peu
surprenante alors j'aurais bien voulu
vous êtes quand même dans un parti de
gouvernement je pense vous venez à
d'ailleurs à plusieurs reprises de
l'évoquer
ces dernières minutes et dont vous serez
forcément confronté à l'épreuve du réel
et puis non nous avons absolument besoin
je trouve que le débat est toujours
intéressant c'est justement ce qu'on va
faire là et la construction a perdu nos
positions et toujours tout à fait
intéressante mais quand l'opposition -
constructive
on ce quelque part c'est même peut-être
moins stimulant pour la majorité que
nous représentons donc sur le sujet de
la sortie de crise sanitaire précisément
en ce moment et la levée progressive des
et des restrictions des mesures qui
avaient été mises en oeuvre
j'aurais voulu savoir madame genevard ce
que vous auriez fait de mieux que nous
sur cette sortie progressive
conditionnelle prudente de la crise
sanitaire alors ce qu'on aurait fait de
mieux c'est ce qu'on a fait de mieux en
réalité dans la gestion de la crise
sanitaire
il n'y a qu'à regarder ce que les
régions ont fait les régions tenues par
les républicains
regardez ce que laurent wauquiez est
fait dans la région auvergne rhône-alpes
en matière de masques en matière de
vaccination en matière d'organisation de
de la gestion de la crise en matière de
tests dans les établissements enfin en
matière de de purificateurs d'air
dans les écoles y a qu'à regarder ce que
les régions ont fait il ya qu à regarder
ce que les maires ont fait ils ont bien
souvent été à contrario de la lenteur
administrative qui était d'une prudence
excessive parfois ou d'une absence de
logistique et de et de mise en oeuvre
dans d'autres cas les masques par
exemple mais là je voulais pas lorsque
nous faisons en ce moment là parce que
oui non mais moi je vous ramène à
l'ensemble de la gestion de la crise
lorsque vous nous avez dit que les
masques étaient inutiles bas on ne vous
a pas suivis en effet on a bien fait de
ne pas vous suivre lorsqu'on vous disais
qu'il fallait davantage de tests et que
les tests étaient comptés qu'il fallait
tester les professeurs vous n'étiez pas
d'accord nous avions raison de le
proposer puisque finalement vouziers
devenus les républicains ont toujours
été dans leur rôle de faire des
propositions c'est la raison pour
laquelle je conteste absolument
l'accusation yakafokon parce que on a
agi sur le terrain les maires ont agi
sur le terrain les républicains comme
d'autres d'ailleurs et les présidents de
région ont été associés à la aux medias
us alors on va sur 210 en matière de
sortie de crise il ya un domaine où la
lenteur a été particulièrement
préjudiciable c'est le domaine culturel
je suis membre la commission des
affaires culturelles et de l'éducation
il faudra que l'on m'explique pourquoi
il était plus dangereux et de fréquenter
amusé plutôt qu'un supermarché par
exemple il a fallu que les républicains
insistent pour qu'on réouvre les
librairies plutôt qu'ils soient
considérés comme des commerces baquero
vous aviez aurore bergé ma collègue
était à l'avancé du ciment osa défense
est libre a donc également la république
à vous ont été utiles ma chère collègue
hubert joly est vous qui êtes à la tête
devant la commission denquête de kobe de
haut c'est là qu'est ce que vous voulez
ajouter à ce débat enfin puis on a une
mission d'information que j'ai l'honneur
présider et qui elle ne s'est pas
dissoute n'a pas explosé en plein vol
pourtant dans la soie je crois que cette
crise sanitaire dont elle nous a appris
beaucoup de choses sur notre système de
santé j'y reviens pas mais elle a ouvert
les yeux sur notre système politique
aussi ou gèrent une épidémie au fond
comme on gère le pays avec le système
politique qu'on a et on a vu donc une
gestion très centralisé au fond très
verticale très descendante très uniforme
au nom du principe d'égalité mais peu
adapté à l'agilité que nécessite une
réponse qui est souvent dans les
territoires et moi un peu ce qui ce qui
par contre la méthode chez les
républicains parce que ce constat je les
partager avec mes collègues au sénat
mots je ne suis pas dans la majorité
sénatoriale mais on l'a tous partagé et
au fond cette cette organisation
politique du pays c'est notre
constitution celle de la vème république
c'est votre mouvement politique qui a un
peu le père ou la mère spirituelle
n'avait pas changé
cette constitution lorsque vous étiez
aux affaires alors les pour les plus
importantes lois de décentralisation
était celle portée par françois
mitterrand je le rappelle tout de même
mais la question elle est pas celle du
20è siècle et celle du xxième siècle
aujourd'hui et pour les années à venir
comment est ce qu'on fait évoluer notre
pays je vous entendu parler de
changement de constitution tout à
l'heure est ce que là il n'y a pas
nécessité de modifier l'organisation de
notre pouvoir politique et administratif
pour sortir un peu de cette verticalité
de cette centralisation d'ailleurs que
vous dénoncez chez le chef de l'état
vous dites vous dites vous aussi vous
faites ce même constat que nous on fait
qu'il ya une hyper centralisation série
manuellement
on a poussé jusqu'à jusqu'à presque la
caricature ces caractéristiques de la
salive ajouté vous pourrez évidemment
les institutions sont ce que les hommes
en font la cinquième là notre
constitution celle de la vème république
est une constitution solide qui a fait
ses preuves et je pense que tout dépend
comment les hommes s'en saisisse la
verticalité des manuels macron je la
conteste tout comme vous et il y a eu
d'autres façons d'exercer un pouvoir
présidentiel sans contrevenir au pouvoir
parlementaire
je pense au quinquennat nicolas sarkozy
qui a donné de la liberté parlementaire
comme jamais avant lui et je pense que
notre système qui donne à l'exécutif un
pouvoir très fort doit être
contrebalancé par un pouvoir local
vous évoquez la décentralisation c'est
une des raisons pour lesquelles la fin
du cumul est une énorme bêtise et puis
par le pouvoir parlementaire
or on voit bien qu'il ya certes le
quinquennat fragiliser le pouvoir
parlementaire là je vous rejoins je
pense que le quinquennat en faisant
coïncider l'élection présidentielle et
l'élection législative à fragiliser le
pouvoir parlementaire
et puis le recours comme on le voit sous
ce quinquennat
dans une une fréquence comme jamais aux
ordonnances dans un contexte particulier
tout de même tout de même on voit bien
avec le parlement l'intéressent guère
notre président de la république et que
nous sommes je ne sais pas s'il a été
traumatisée par les frondeurs lorsqu'il
était ministre de l'économie de françois
hollande ou lorsqu'il était secrétaire
général adjoint de l'elysée mais en tout
cas on sent bien qu'il y a une grande
méfiance à l'égard du pouvoir
parlementaire alors même qu'il est
possible de dans une relation équilibrée
entre les différentes composantes de
notre vie démocratique
il est possible de mieux équilibrer les
choses donc moi je ne suis pas comme la
france est soumise partisane d'une vième
république mais je crois que nos
institutions ne doivent pas être je
dirais trahi par un par une verticalité
excessive du pouvoir exécutif ben
geôlier à la jeune tu es si je peux
l'aider je suis plus facilement la crise
sanitaire sur les fai re centralisation
que vous évoquiez tout âge donc renvoyé
au rapport de didier pittet ce rapport
qui était à l'origine à une demande
d'ailleurs de dole msa plusieurs pays
qui souligne qu'en fait il n'y a pas eu
forcément de bonnes solutions qui
avaient des pays beaucoup moins
centralisée je pense notamment à
l'allemagne qui a aussi connu sur
d'autres aspects de la gestion de crise
des difficultés que finalement il dit
lui même qu'il est probablement des
bonnes choses à prendre dans un système
comme dans l'autre de mauvaises choses
dans un système comme dans l'autre ac
origines je crois que avant de jeter le
bébé avec l'eau du bain
il faut peut-être être plus prudent il
voir comment on peut en tout cas
certainement tirer les leçons de cette
crise était moi je suis voisine de la
suisse je peux vous dire qu'en suisse a
s'est pas passé de la même façon qu'on a
beaucoup moins fragilisé l'économie ils
ont pas déficit comme nous le
connaissons aujourd'hui ils n'ont pas
une économie qui a souffert autant que
la nôtre et ils n'ont pas eu plus de
victimes du coc vides il y avait sans
doute d'autres façons de faire il faudra
en tirer tous les enseignements parce
que lorsque comme vous le dites
mon cher collègue sénateur il ya une
centralisation de la décision c'est nous
acteurs de terrain élus de terrain qui
apprenions quelquefois aux représentants
de la rs la situation sur le terrain ce
n'était pas possible
et puis cette gestion uniquement
centrale us
sur l'hôpital c'est l'hôpital qui a
déterminé toute la politique sanitaire
du pays ça il faudra bien que nous en
tirions les conséquences ça a déjà été
évoquée puisque on sait déjà qu'il ya un
travail qui est fait actuellement pour
améliorer le lien ville hôpital dans le
cadre de la politique de la santé
depuis le début ça on a une loi qui
arrive là la loi cadre d enfin qu a
perdu l'un des kills 3d qui sont la
décentralisation et cette loi elle a une
toute petite partie sur la santé qui
traitent des agences régionales de santé
en disant il faut que les élus voilà et
quelques rôles dans la gestion des
agences régionales de santé
et puis elle autorise les collectivités
territoriales à investir dans le champ
de la santé c'est à dire à payer mais
pas vraiment à décider est ce que quand
même là on n'est plus en train de
ramener
voilà un rendez vous enfin il n'est pas
encore raté la loi va arriver devant les
députés
mais d'abord devant le sénat début
juillet puis devant les députés
au mois de septembre est-ce que c'est
pas le moment où quand même il faudrait
mener une évolution significative parce
que j'entends la réussite sur la
stabilité politique de la constitution
actuelle
mais même si là il n'est pas question de
toucher la constitution mais la
répartition des pouvoirs entre le centre
et les collectivités territoriales
laisse tout de même apparaître un
déséquilibre qui sur la gestion de la
pandémie n'a pas été profitable n'a pas
permis de mobiliser à à bon escient
l'ensemble des acteurs des territoires
et l'ensemble des acteurs du système de
santé
au delà du système hospitalier lorsque
agnès buzyn et ministre la santé je lui
avais
suggérer j'avais même fait plus que lui
suggérer puisque j'avais déposé un
amendement pour que les parlementaires
soient membres des instances de la rs
les parlementaires étaient les seuls à
n'être pas représentée à la rs bon elle
avait refusé cet amendement est par la
suite elle l'a acceptée venant d'un
membre de la majorité
elles sont tout ça pour dire que et
lorsque je lui en avais parlé elle
m'avait fait une réponse tout à fait
symptomatique elle m'avait dit les ars
n'aime pas beaucoup que les politiques
se mêlent de leurs affaires
eh bien je pense que cette réponse qui
correspond à la réalité sans doute à
l'état d'esprit d'un certain nombre de
directeurs des agences régionales de
santé traduit exactement le fond du
problème
nous avons une administration qui voit
dans les élus des gêneurs alors que les
élus voient la réalité du terrain bien
plus finement que même et je regrette
profondément et je pense à la santé
on parle on parle on parle bien sûr mais
ça 10 à duilhac la question est plus
large que le domaine de la santé oui la
santé de la crise ont jamais de mazamet
ont les préfets heureusement que nous
avions les préfets issus les élus locaux
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je suis
absolument hostile à la réforme qui est
en cours en fac et qui est prévu pour
réformer le corps préfectoral
moi je crois pourtant c'est une réforme
qui va justement leur permet d'aller
beaucoup plus sur le terrain notamment
début de carrière
écoutez moi je pars d'un principe simple
madame gntc que ce qui marche
il est raisonnable de ne pas y toucher
vial trouve alors ça fonctionne plutôt
bien essayé quelque chose aussi qui va
marquer le cac est là probablement c'est
en tout cas ça traîne j'allais dire
depuis le début du quinquennat et vous
êtes vous allée des matelas dessus tout
les deux et tous les trois avec annie
genevard c'est la loi bioéthique alors
quand on dit nous et bioéthique on a
parlé plus tôt loi p massa a été plus
salée dommage parce qu'elle est très
riche et beaucoup donné mais rares
juillet va en parler justement d'un
autre aspect b vous
vouliez justement aller sur la question
de la pma procréation médicalement
assistée pour les femmes
absolument là ce qu'on appelle la pma
pour tout parce que aujourd'hui dans la
majorité
présenté dans la dans la majorité parmi
les républicains en majorité entre une
majorité d'entre eux pardon considère
enfin nous faut un petit peu jouer les
hypocrites ils
pour moi ils ferment un peu les yeux sur
la réalité la réalité elle est
qu'aujourd'hui la pma pour toutes
elles existent elles existent chez nos
voisins elle existe en france hélas de
manière clandestine est là je vais
prendre deux secondes mais casquette de
médecins j'ai coutume de dire que pour
avoir vu dans mon cabinet en
lorsque j'exerçais encore une femme qui
a un désir d'enfant c'est un rouleau
compresseur
elle fera tout pour faire aboutir son
désir d'enfant
donc dans ce contexte la fermer les yeux
sur la pma me laisse encore perplexe
la paire m'apporterait les yeux ou
s'opposer s'opposer c'est un sens opposé
pardonnable pour moi le projet de deux
mères de famille le projet d'enfant sera
donc absolument toujours toujours plus
fort que tout donc la question je
voudrais vous poser madame genevard
c'est pourquoi est ce que vous voulez
absolument fermer les yeux sur cette
réalité pourquoi acceptez-vous pas de
sécuriser sur le plan juridique ce qui
est aujourd'hui une réalité parce que
finalement vous avez aussi dit parfois
que élever un enfant sans père la pma et
et pour tout était élevé un enfant son
père aujourd'hui nous avons un enfant
sur deux en france qui vit avec un seul
de ses deux parents nous avons beaucoup
d'enfants qui se retrouvaient là
savaient qu'un seul de leurs deux
groupes d'états brise ont commencé
depuis toujours par hélas des décès donc
je ne suis pas certaine que la condition
un pape est repêché mais reçoit celle de
rendre un enfant heureux
pourquoi refusez vous de sécuriser sur
le plan juridique la pma porte ou alors
avant de vous en donner les raisons je
voudrais dire que il y a une faille dans
votre raisonnement
parce que la loi n'est pas faite pour
comment dirais-je prendre acte d'une
situation illégale et la rendre légal la
loi n'est pas faite pour légaliser ce
qui n'est pas légal
parce que sinon on suit votre
raisonnement est bien nous devrons
accepter la gpa la gestation pour autrui
qui se pratique clandestinement dans
notre pays donc cet argument là je ne
leur soit pas
en revanche je pense que la question
qu'il faut se poser est du reste madame
belloubet foulée des rubans comme garde
des sceaux a eu l'honnêteté de dire
qu'il s'agissait d'un changement de
civilisation et je crois en effet que
c'est un changement de civilisation et
que quand on change de civilisation ce
n'est pas moi qui le dit c'est votre
ministre qui l'a dit en son temps
ça mérite quand même qu'on se pose un
certain nombre de questions
moi je ne me place pas du point de vue
de la femme je me place du point de vue
de l'enfant
je pense que on n'a pas droit à l'enfant
l'enfant il a des droits et dans toutes
les conventions qui expriment les droits
de l'enfant il y a le droit d'avoir et
de connaître ses parents
la deuxième chose qui me choque dans ses
textes de loi c'est l'éviction de la
biologie c'est à dire que il ya deux
absents dans ce texte en réalité il y à
l'enfant qui s'efface derrière le désir
des parents vous avez dit une femme qui
veut un enfant c'est un rouleau
compresseur
donc le désir du dieu de la existe déjà
le désir de l'adulte est supérieur à
l'intérêt de l'enfant moi ça c'est pas
comme ça que je conçois les choses
deuxième le deuxième absent c'est le
père le deuxième absence et le père
puisque il n'y a plus de père il y à des
gammes est le géniteur n'est même plus
un géniteur c'est un spermatozoïde point
à la ligne
donc pour moi l'éviction de l'intérêt de
l'enfant et l'éviction du père sont en
effet constitutifs d'un vrai changement
de civilisation pourtant ça existe déjà
et aujourd'hui vous avez des défunts
j'ajoute que on a réussi à éviter quand
même que la mère qui accouchent ne
doivent aller chez le notaire pour
déclarer qu'elle était bien la mère
alors que c'est un principe absolu dans
la filiation dans le droit de la
filiation que la femme qui accouche et
toujours que journal la mer alors vous
lisiez c'est dommage qu'on s'arrête
seulement la question de la paix m
je n'y ai justement voulait évoquer un
autre aspect de cette loi c'est la
question des cellules souches alors vous
allez nous redire rapidement de quoi il
s'agit et posez votre question oui alors
je sais pas si on est en changement
civilisationnel par ailleurs choix
surtout journée on est là dans l'est on
était dans l'évolution sociétale avec la
pma là on est sur les questions
effectivement de bioéthique c'est à dire
que la recherche a beaucoup progressé
depuis une dizaine d'années sur les
cellules souches les cellules
embryonnaires c'est à dire des cellules
en fait qu on prélève pas sur de
nouveaux embryons cd des cultures de
cellules qui existe depuis des décennies
on utilise toujours les mêmes on les
fait se reproduire et on est en cas pas
dans la borat war ii face et ça on est
en capacité par exemple au cea où je
suis allé avec la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat avec les
présidents de la commission voit leurs
travaux et ont fait des recherches sur
des maladies des maladies génétiques et
c'est comme ça par exemple un exemple
puisque je bouge mes lunettes il ya une
maladie la rétine très grave qui est
maintenant traité qui alors qu'elle ne
pouvait pas l'être avant grâce à ses
recherches et l'autre fois en france est
très en retard très très en retard on
interdit à nos chercheurs de faire des
tas de choses qu'on fait dans les autres
pays européens y compris avec des grands
mots parce que là les postures vont vite
l'eau risque d'eugénisme de sectionner
bon c'est comme ça que une de nos prix
plus brillants de chercheuse ailleurs
qui a obtenu le prix nobel a quitté la
france elle avait découvert la
technologie des ciseaux moléculaires
je vais pas m'étendre met donc moi j'ai
été très surpris parce que il fallait
dans cette loi on veut à dire permettre
à nos chercheurs de poursuivre des
recherches en respectant les fondements
notre éthique bien sûr le texte qui a
été proposée par le gouvernement était
plutôt satisfaisant à cet égard et les
républicains ont détricoté ce texte et
se sont opposés à toute avancée en la
matière on a vu les tribunes de
scientifiques se multiplier pour tirer
la sonnette d'alarmé et vous êtes resté
globalement sur cette position pourquoi
alors je dois dire que là on est
véritablement dans la partie bio éthique
de la loi la pma n'est pas du tout une
loi de bioéthique c'est pour ça qu'il
aurait fallu deux musées dans la même
loi il aurait fallu de loi parce que oui
mais c'est dans l'action médicalement
assistée c'est connu c'est une c'est une
technique qui est connue donc sur vous
vous opposez manche en revanche la
deuxième partie celle qui vient d'être
évoquée on est vraiment dans la
bioéthique et la france a une voix
singulière en matière du bétique sire
que la france a toujours considéré que
tout ce qui est scientifiquement
possible n'est pas forcément éthiquement
souhaitable les autres pays haussier
faut pas faire un jour d'été aux
européens bat pas dans les proportions
la france a toujours été pionnière en
matière de bioéthique et là encore je
pense que notre parlement s'honore
d'avoir un vrai débat de fond sur le
statut de l'embryon et sur le statut des
cellules souches embryonnaires
il ya une chose que je veux évoquer et
qui dans cette loi
d'ailleurs les français lorsque nous
leur en parle on sont horrifiés ce sont
les chimères c'est à dire l'introduction
de cellules humaines dans un embryon
animal ça n'est pas possible et ça donne
ça vous donne la mesure lorsque des
scientifiques nous disent on ne peut pas
introduire plus de 30% parce qu'on n'est
pas sûr qu'au delà de 30% ne se
développe pas une conscience humaine
comment voulez vous qu'on ne se pose pas
d'argent vous le savez vous savez très
bien il n'a jamais été question il n'est
pas question de laisser un être vivant
naître de ces cultures de cellules
mais vous savez comme moi que un quart à
un tiers des femmes font une fausse
couche dans les premières semaines de
leur grossesse et notamment au bout dans
les quinze premiers jours
et d'ailleurs ça passe inaperçu en
général au bout de deux semaines
et pourquoi est ce qu'elles font des
fausses couches et bien mené des
recherches sur cette période là
nécessite d'aller faire ses recherches
pour le bien des enfants à naître et non
pas sur des clichés de leur relative on
a cédé alternait des femmes cellules
souches embryonnaires dans certaines
zones et on va s'arrêter au-dessus dans
certains pays vous le savez il ya des
recherches des expériences qui sont
conduites au mépris de tout principes
bioéthiques notamment les cellules de
reproduction les salue
pays c'est pas la loi française n'est
pas leur projet ça n'était pas le bon
jour on doit toujours penser qu'on
puisse faire le pire en pensant avoir à
un moment donné travailler pour le
meilleur g12 conception qui s'oppose
donc on va faire des tours rapides
maintenant par le figaro live nous
attend un sens au bon soir vincent vous
allez le dire ce que les internautes et
vos lecteurs ont noté les spectateurs
ont retenu ou où je vous font circuler
en tout cas bon soit bannie jeunes va
donc il ya beaucoup intéressé les
internautes du figaro en tout cas ce qui
a suscité beaucoup d'attention et
beaucoup de commentaires c'est la tacc
ce week-end par des antilles des anti
fades une procession catholique en
mémoire des prêtres et évêques massacrés
lors de la commune deux sexagénaires ont
d'ailleurs été sérieusement blessé
certains internautes déplore qu'il n'y a
eu très peu de réactions politiques
est ce que vous les comprenez moi je
pense que c'est ce qui s'est passé est
profondément choquant c'est catholique
faisaient une procession en mémoire de
l'évêque de paris qui a été assassiné au
moment de la commune c'était une
procession des plus pacifiques qui
commémorer un événement de l'histoire de
france il n'y avait là absolument pas
matière à je dirais les attaques dont
ils ont été l'objet
c'est très choquant en effet pourquoi
n'y a pas eu plus de réactions
politiques vous demandez vincent oui bah
écoutez moi je suis extrêmement choquée
je pense je voulais que sur ces
questions religieuses
la loi séparatisme bien loin d'apaiser
les conflits les les enjeux nîmes parce
que laisse à penser que toutes les
religions sont fautes sont peuvent être
la cause de troubles or il ne faut pas
il ne faut pas mettre sur le même plan
toutes les religions il y a des formes
des voiliers de certaines religions et
là c'est pas le cas
merci vincent merci vincent si les merci
à john t merci bernard jomier d'avoir
des battues avec annie genevard merci
d'avoir accepté de participer à
l'édition publique qui revient lundi en
direct à 19h30 bonne soirée
[Musique]